do you think you still need be honest
you always are do you think you need a
lot of external validation do you like
to hear Stephen is great at this Stephen
is good at this is something you need is
it something you just it's nice to hear
but I know inside that my I I'm
validated because I respect myself and I
know I'm doing a good job it's a
combination of both I don't need it it's
nice though it is it is really nice
um when I'm not doing something at this
point like when I'm not promoting the
second season of heels or I'm not
promoting the second code eight I like
to I like to disappear I'm not looking
to I'm not looking to do or be you do
Disappear by anybody I like to disappear
but at a certain point at a certain
point the proverbial IMDb star meter
starts to creep down a little bit and
and you want that you you sh you want it
to you want it to pop back up